y
[Música]
los bombardeos no se sanen gaza e israel
pese al llamado internacional al cese de
hostilidades el primer ministro israelí
benjamín netanyahu declaró que las
operaciones armadas continuarán con
mucha intensidad el ejército israelí
bombardeó en estos cinco días de
conflicto a cientos de objetivos de las
milicias de hamás en gaza y llevó a cabo
ataques que han matado a más de 30
miembros de movimientos islamistas y
cobrado decenas de víctimas civiles
los centros de control y prevención de
enfermedades de eeuu indicaron que la
población vacunada contra el coi 19
podrá prescindir del uso de la
mascarilla tanto en interiores como en
exteriores así lo voy a conocer la
directora del organismo rochelle
valensky sin embargo deberán portar la
en aviones buses digitales
las elecciones locales y regionales de
venezuela se celebrarán el próximo 21 de
noviembre mientras que la campaña
electoral va a comenzar el 28 de octubre
así informó el presidente del consejo
nacional electoral
el anuncio llega cuando tanto nicolás
maduro como el líder opositor juan
guaidó han manifestado disposición a
dialogar tenemos reportes desde caracas
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si río blanco como
siempre un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos
el ejército de israel lanzó su mayor
operación contra la franja de gaza desde
que volvieron a estallar las tensiones
fuertes bombardeos desde israel
destruyeron parte de la infraestructura
del grupo hamas como uno de sus
importantes túneles subterráneos las
víctimas mortales entre los palestinos
ya son 119 mientras que los fallecidos
de israelíes aumentaron hasta los 8 el
grupo hamas continúa atacando a los
israelíes lanzando cohetes hacia tel
aviv desde casa y en las últimas horas
se conoció que tres cohetes fueron
disparados desde el líbano para romero
sala nos cuenta más
500 rondas de bombardeos en 40 minutos
por tierra y aire el ejército de israel
lanzó una intensa ofensiva sobre la
franja de gaza- la mayor operación desde
la nueva escalada de tensiones
el primer ministro israelí ya lo había
advertido dije que le daría a pagar un
alto precio a hamás y otras
organizaciones terroristas continuaremos
con esta operación el tiempo que haga
falta para restaurar la paz y
tranquilidad del estado de israel'
los ataques destruyeron edificios y se
cobraron más víctimas mortales entre los
palestinos la cifra ya supera el
centenar
esta familia solo pudo alcanzar el
refugio de una escuela de las naciones
unidas- cuando los bombardeos se dieron
por el exterior
planeábamos signos por la noche pero los
drones y aviones no dejaban de
bombardearnos cuando nos despertamos
encontramos todo destruido no queda nada
lejos de atenuarse las tensiones siguen
aumentando las tropas de israelíes se
agrupan en la frontera en la madrugada
del viernes el ejército anunció su
entrada en la franja de gaza- para luego
desmentir lo un movimiento que podría
llegar en cualquier momento
las milicias palestinas mantienen sus
ataques aéreos la última noche
dispararon 50 misiles contra israel
además dos misiles más fueron lanzados
desde el sur de líbano un ataque sin
autoría clara y los esfuerzos de
mediación de la delegación egipcia que
viajó hasta tel aviv no dieron frutos
los mediadores ya dejaron israel
convencidos de que el gobierno rechaza
cualquier posibilidad de alto al fuego
el domingo el consejo de seguridad de la
onu se reunirá para discutir la
situación en la región
y eeuu continúa en su afán de tener
vacunada el 70 por ciento de la
población antes del 4 de julio ayer
anunció que todas aquellas personas
completamente inmunizadas no estarán
obligadas a usar tapabocas en espacios
cerrados con algunas excepciones como
hospitales o residencias de ancianos
rodrigo sedano nos cuenta los detalles
este pequeño gesto implicará también
esta nueva realidad los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedades
informaron el jueves que las personas
inmunizadas no estarán obligadas a usar
tapabocas en interiores igual todo el
que esté vacunado por completo podrá
participar en actividades en interiores
y exteriores grandes o pequeñas sin usar
mascarilla o respetar la distancia
física es una más de las propuestas de
las autoridades en su afán de incentivar
a los estadounidenses a vacunarse e
incluso se está ofreciendo vacunas
gratis a los turistas debido al riesgo
de caducidad de las dosis y el costo que
implica mantener las condiciones
logísticas para mantenerlas refrigeradas
en nueva york se ofrecen tiquetes de
metro sin costo a todos aquellos que
quieran inocularse el antídoto y en
miami se aplica a todos los que pasen
por el aeropuerto tras conocer el
relajamiento del uso del tapabocas el
presidente joe biden declaró que es un
hito para el país si bien quiso recalcar
que cada ciudadano es responsable de
hacer un uso adecuado de la medida y si
la elección es vuestra todos vosotros
hacéis que esto sea posible
acabamos el trabajo de ganar el virus y
hacer que todo vuelva a la normalidad el
uso del tapabocas ha provocado una
polarización en la sociedad
estadounidense alentada por los
comentarios en su contra del ex
presidente de donald trump
en su discurso baiden hizo también un
llamado a que esta medida no cause más
confrontación vive tu match camp ya
hemos tenido demasiado conflicto
demasiada amargura demasiada ira
demasiada polarización por el uso del
tapabocas pese a todo se sigue
recomendando el uso de mascarillas en
medios de transporte colectivos y
seguirá siendo obligatorio en hospitales
o residencias de ancianos debido al
riesgo de contacto para otras personas y
en colombia sigue estancado el diálogo
entre el gobierno y los organizadores
del parón que busca calmar las protestas
sociales contra el gobierno y presidente
iván duque entretanto organizaciones
sociales y el senador iván cepeda
denunciaron ante la corte penal
internacional y el consejo de seguridad
de naciones unidas presuntos crímenes de
lesa humanidad por los hechos de
violencia policial en las
manifestaciones
y vamos ahora hasta venezuela donde ayer
el consejo nacional electoral del país
anunció que las elecciones locales y
regionales se van a celebrar el próximo
21 de noviembre y la campaña electoral
comenzará el 28 de octubre el presidente
del órgano electoral le aseguro que la
convocatoria a estas elecciones es el
resultado del empeño democrático de los
venezolanos todo esto se da cuando el
presidente nicolás maduro se mostró
dispuesto a dialogar con el líder
opositor juan guaidó quien lo invitó a
buscar soluciones a la crisis política
del país más temprano conversamos con
nuestra corresponsal nico el call stern
quien nos contó por qué se están dando
estos llamados al diálogo y qué
disposición real hay entre negociar por
parte de maduro y la oposición para
participar en unas elecciones veamos lo
que nos dijo
no es que haya una haya terminado la
guerra de declaraciones éstas se
mantienen cambia ahora si el llamado a
negociar de pongo hay 2 líder de la
oposición venezolana que coloca estas
sanciones internacionales en la mesa y
maduro que ya ha dialogado con otros
sectores de la oposición dice que acepta
esta mediación esta mediación
internacional recordemos que estas
elecciones fueron convocadas en el día
de ellas por el poder electoral
y entonces la posición
tres veces para poner
desde acuerdo
a estas elecciones de una manera unida
ella una parte de la oposición alejada a
la del líder de la oposición juan guaidó
se había sentado de una forma con el
gobierno a nicolás maduro a hablar sobre
unas condiciones electorales juan guaidó
de fondos de este consejo nacional
electoral pero hay una fracción pequeña
de la oposición que si lo acepta
era nuestra corresponsal desde la ciudad
de caracas en icod el colchester
nosotros continuamos con más información
el mundo debe actuar ahora para frenar
el calentamiento global de lo contrario
habrá una catástrofe climática así lo
afirmó el presidente de la cob 26 a loc
sharma sharma ex ministro de negocios de
reino unido y miembro del gabinete del
primer ministro británico boris johnson
aseguró durante una visita al parque
eólico al suroeste de glasgow que la
actividad humana está dañando la tierra
y que urge reducir las emisiones
globales reino unido- alberga la
conferencia climática con 26 en la
ciudad más grande de escocia en el mes
de noviembre de este año
japón anunció que ampliará el estado de
emergencia sanitaria a tres prefecturas
más ante la continua propagación del cob
y 19 que llevó a niveles récord las
cifras en algunas regiones a dos meses y
medio de los juegos olímpicos' el estado
de emergencia en japón no conlleva a un
confinamiento de la población ni toques
de queda aunque se insta a los
residentes a evitar salidas no
esenciales y a las empresas a que
fomenten el teletrabajo para reducir los
desplazamientos por su parte el
organizador de la campaña contra los
juegos olímpicos' presentó formalmente
al gobernador de tokio una petición
pidiendo la cancelación de estas justas
que ha obtenido más de 350.000 firmas a
pesar de esto el primer ministro de
japón yoshihiko anunció que protegerá a
las personas de japón mediante fuertes
medidas de bioseguridad y que se
realizarán unos juegos olímpicos seguros
vamos a ver entonces qué pasa con estos
juegos olímpicos de toque y por supuesto
vamos a tener actualizaciones de una
rueda de prensa que tenía en estos
momentos el primer ministro japonés por
lo pronto me despido de ustedes continuó
con nosotros para más actualizaciones de
noticias
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde julio de 2020